my name is George ishara I am a global
changemaker from Kenya I actually
believe that the world cup will really
mean a lot to Kenya I'm into Africa and
all and specifically South Africa in two
ways to fundamental ways one is economy
the other one is a cultural exchange the
economy of Africa shall be more or less
improved in by consumption because we
have a lot of people coming into Africa
into South Africa and into the
neighboring countries around South
Africa for accommodation for food for
travel for tour around the time of World
Cup and also cultural exchange that
Kenya I mean that Africa shall be seen
not as the jungle with lions all over
but with people and with cultures that
are progressive with their
infrastructure and the opportunities
that exist in in Africa so I think the
world cup is pretty a good thing and
also it shall elevate our soccer and and
our standards also of infrastructure of
communication and security must also
increase at the same so that's my
opinion thank you